do you get embarrassed when you order
from the two places and they sync up
you're like that was dominoes and Winx
Club literally the other night man the
wings came first the other day and then
I was like looking on the tracker and I
saw the other one coming up the hill I'm
like yo
bounce dude I got another one please
please I was going to get the bag of
wings and the guy pulled up I'm like ah
it's like close the door and then the
dude walks up with the pizza and I could
tell he was calculating he was like you
saw me we made eye contact no no no no
he saw the wings okay I think he like
might have heard me try to grab him
so the way
yeah it just like kind of gave up
where'd These Wings come from no because
then he'll do the awkward things like I
could take him well you know how long
they've been here I got food poisoning
what flavor they are yeah
it could be shitty flavor